goldman sachs ubs bank of america
deutsche bank blackrock pimco credit
suisse they've all been writing notes to
their clients in recent weeks warning
that a recession has become more likely
but money managers at big banks aren't
just talking about a recession
they're betting on it how do i know
financial markets have an almost endless
amount of contracts derivatives and
securities that allow investors to bet
on just about anything by reading the
movement of some of these securities we
can see how investors are positioning
themselves for the future and whether
they expect the economy to grow or
contract here are four important market
metrics that show how investors are
pricing in higher chances of a recession
[Music]
the first is a brand new metric from the
federal reserve called the corporate
bond market distress index which began
publishing in june second is inflation
break-even rates which track the
movement of inflation-protected
securities versus old-fashioned u.s
government bonds third is the five-year
five-year forward inflation rate which
looks at shorter dated bonds in
comparison to longer ones and finally
there's the u.s treasury yield curve
they've got some long and complicated
sounding names but don't worry i'm going
to break them all down and explain why
they matter are we at a turning point
headed for a recession yes the stock
market is down but each one of these
metrics follows the bond market because
bond market investors are generally
thought to be more concerned with the
overall health and direction of the
economy than stock investors the
corporate bond market distress index or
cmdi tracks measures of bond issuance
liquidity and trading patterns to show
how fearful investors are all of those
words just mean that the fed is tracking
the flow of bonds fewer companies
selling bonds and fewer investors buying
them typically means trouble and vice
versa break even inflation rates show
how investors believe inflation will
move over a given period of time the
government sells bonds to investors and
it also sells inflation-protected
securities or tips break-even inflation
is calculated by subtracting the amount
that investors get paid for ordinary
government debt versus what they get
paid to hold tips over the same time
horizon this number represents what
inflation would have to be in order for
investors to break even or earn the same
return from buying tips instead of
regular treasury bonds the higher it is
the higher they expect inflation to be
five year five year forwards are a more
nuanced way of looking at inflation
expectations in 10 years they're called
that because they look at inflation
expectations five years from now and
then five years after that the raid also
uses tips versus regular government
bonds but the point of five year five
year forwards is that a bit of caution
to investors expectations of the future
by comparing five-year inflation
expectations to 10-year inflation
expectations you can throw some water on
predictions that are a little too hot or
too cold the treasury yield curve tracks
the rates investors are demanding to
hold government bonds that mature at
different time periods from one month to
30 years shorter maturities should pay
less since loans are more likely to be
paid back over shorter time periods but
when that stops being the case you get
what's known as a yield curve inversion
the yield curve is inverted before every
single recession since the 1950s i did a
full video breakdown of the treasury
yield curve and its ability to predict
recessions in march check that out for a
deeper explanation so now that you know
what they mean here's what each of these
measures is telling us right now the
corporate bond market distress index was
elevated in june and is showing some
distress in the bond market fed
researchers found that the index would
have spiked during previous times of
turmoil like the 2008 financial crisis
the european debt crisis and early 2020.
the first reading shows increased fear
in the bond market but is well below
what we would have seen from the index
in 2008 break-even inflation rates have
been sinking in recent weeks even as
inflation readings for this year have
been rising that shows investors expect
inflation will be low in the future even
though it's very high today that
typically signals fears of a recession
because a recession stops growth
bringing down the average rate for
inflation over time the five-year
five-year forward rate is even lower and
recently fell to its lowest rate since
march that suggests longer term growth
expectations are really being decreased
which also signals recession fears and
the treasury yield curve recently
inverted for the second time this year
the yield curve shows investors predict
central banks will need to lower
interest rates in the future that's
usually because a recession has happened
all of these gauges show that investors
are putting more of their bets on a
recession or at least a significant
economic downturn but that doesn't mean
it's guaranteed to happen
rapper yg made a hit song this year by
telling us that scared money don't make
no money but sometimes it does
that's all for now i'll see you next
time
you